thanks to Canon for sponsoring a portion of
this video this is a one-terabyte micro SD card
it's insane that we can fit so much data onto
something small enough to eat this on the other
hand is a floppy disk or what some of you might
call the save button it holds 1.44 megabytes of
space but how many of these could equal this
well let me tell you well for one and a half
million dollars we acquired 700 happiness look how
glorious this deck is it's so tall I don't know
man this seems really unstable I think it might
fall I mean it might but you know what it's not
real we'll be fine come with me on a journey into
the past and the future as I use visual effects
and accurate math to show you something you've
never seen before the true scale of data no no no
most of you are probably familiar with memory
cards we put them in our cameras to store the
photos and videos that we capture such as the
EOS r10 because this portion of the video is
sponsored by Canon are you a Creator looking
to up your game well guess what the Canon EOS
r10 is a pretty great camera Canon took the best
features of their R series and put them in a super
lightweight body like this dude so lightweight but
you're like ah this is 2022 I want high resolution
well guess what you get it this shoots 4K video
and if you're shooting photos 24.2 megapixel
Stills I got my own start in film using a Canon
camera a lot like this and this is so much better
for one thing the autofocus is lightning fast
you literally just like point at anything and
it's already focused before your brain even knows
what it happened it's a mirrorless camera and it
pairs so nicely with Canon RF lenses also this
thing will actually shoot for longer than 30
minutes I've been using these types of cameras for
long enough that like that's actually a big deal
if you are interested click that link down in the
description to check out the Canon EOS r10 thanks
to Canon again for sponsoring this portion of the
video but let's get back to the episode because I
want to show you my first memory card about 15
years ago I invested in a massive one gigabyte
memory card for my camera which was a big deal
back then for a kid like me however these days
if I saw one on the street next to a quarter I'll
be honest I'm probably more likely to pick up the
quarter the gig just doesn't really have much
value anymore it's hard for me to wrap my head
around the fact that although these are roughly
similar in size one holds a thousand times more
than the other I mean imagine showing this to a
computer scientist 60 years ago it'd blow their
minds a computer that can fit into a single room
and hold millions of pieces of information Jesus
the scale of just how big our data storage
has gotten is nearly impossible to imagine
it's that big so megabytes gigabytes you
probably already understand these terms but
do you know what a zettabyte is these terms
help us deal with huge numbers by putting
them into groups of a thousand so a thousand
bytes is a kilobyte a thousand kilobytes is
a megabyte a thousand megabytes is a gigabyte
thousand you get the idea but what's above this
well it goes petabyte then exabyte then zettabyte
which is a billion terabytes this is literally
incomprehensibly large but don't worry we'll
revisit zettabytes before this video is over it's
easy to take for granted that we stream pretty
much everything we want when we want it but that
wasn't always the case if you wanted to own movies
or music you needed this optical storage this is
a 4K Blu-ray which can hold 50 gigabytes per
disk so with only a small stack of 20 I have a
terabyte DVDs on the other hand they only hold
five gigabytes per disk so I need 212 of them
to do the same thing these hold the same amount
of data these two different Stacks here and yes
I know the Blu-rays are like black and the DVDs
are blue whatever I don't get it what about the
CD well at 700 megabytes per compact disc you end
up with a stack about as tall as a person oh this
is a lot heavier than it looks I'm sure some of
you've got like a whole terabytes worth of music
CDs stashed away in those little pocket binders
I know I'm looking at you oh gosh it's called
the compact disc truthfully I didn't realize
the CD first came out back in 1982. that was
seven when they crossed 200 billion units sold
maybe it's just hard for my brain to accept that
a computer technology can be so integrated into
society without Ever Changing let's do a show
of hands how many of you have a CD player in your
car but as with all change it took a while for the
CD to actually like catch on in 1994 Bill Gates
advertised the value of the kind of brand new
but invented 12 years ago technology by sitting on
330 000 sheets of paper the idea is actually very
similar to this video he demonstrated you can
store thousands of books worth of information
in the palm of his hand look at all the paper
I'm saving says the guy literally wasting paper
the photo was taken 28 years ago so I think
it's time to update the comparison however
instead of holding a CD I'm gonna be holding a
one terabyte memory card so now the question is
how tall is the paper going to be well if
we assume Williams calculations are correct
a sheet of paper can hold 2.12 kilobytes of
information now I can easily afford the 470
million pages of paper but no one could
give me an answer on how to safely hold
me Steady at 26 kilometers altitude they said
it was like too dangerous or something stupid
like that man I was really looking forward to
chilling at the cruising altitude of the SR-71
so why was the CD such a big deal well it
marked the change to optical storage from
magnetic storage have you ever seen what's inside
of a floppy disk it's basically the same kind of
stuff as what's inside of VHS and cassette
tape because it stores data magnetically but
the data here is coiled into a spiral disk hence
floppy disk this is the form factor most of us
are familiar with but they actually started out
way larger and held way less and inside of these
hard plastic shells they were indeed floppy the
shells helped to prevent dirt from becoming a
problem 1.44 megabytes is all that these things
held that's not even enough to hold the average
amount of data a person generates every single
second during the space age of NASA scientists
had to get creative with how to store memory
they use these hand-woven bits of wire and
carbon Rings called core memory how did it work I
actually honestly have no idea hey I'm sorry I'm
a mechanical engineer not electrical but according
to Scott manlet it could fit a few terabytes worth
of core memory into the actual buildings used
to build Rockets this right here is a single
bit given to me by Adam Savage when I visited his
shop earlier this year it was invented for the IBM
604 a computer so Advanced it could do subtraction
plus multiplication and division state of the art
stuff back then a bit is the smallest form of data
possible it can only store on or off yes or no one
or zero it's binary which means to hold any useful
amount of information you need eight of them to
store a single byte this right here is just enough
Hardware to contain the information of a single
character of text we know that a sheet of paper
can hold a couple kilobytes of data at eight bits
per byte that means seventeen thousand bits can
hold the same information as this suddenly a piece
of paper seems pretty dang efficient huh but what
would a terabyte look like this is 8 trillion bits
74 years ago a terabyte was um challenging but
honestly these days it's kind of nothing I mean
our studio deals with hundreds of terabytes
in fact I think the server we have here at
Corridor is the biggest on YouTube uh maybe
not the biggest but we've all got to start
somewhere right oh okay yeah no that's pretty
big uh yeah I mean it isn't that big though not
that I'm jealous or anything a petabyte is just
one step above a terabyte so Linus's server is
really two and a half thousand terabytes
in size which I happen to have right here
now these are all 3D printed because my order of
two and a half thousand micro SD cards got lost in
the mail in theory though this is how big Linus's
server could be so Linus what are you doing man
wasting all that space come on this
is this is actually very satisfying
fun fact though this is around the
same data capacity as our brains
seriously add up all the synapses it's about two
and a half petabytes so now I'm just wondering
why doesn't Linus use this as his server you're
actually not the first to think of using a pile
of commodity SD cards to build out a storage
array in fact we did a video about it four
and a half years ago unfortunately there are a
number of problems with this approach first and
foremost being that it's just not cost effective
a one terabyte SD card that's affordable enough
that large video productions would generally
consider them to be disposable a thousand of them
yeah not so much that's about nine times the
cost of a petabyte of traditional mechanical
hard drives a hard drive or even a regular SSD
will often begin spitting out errors weeks or
even months before it dies out right giving you
time to hopefully back up your data SD cards
well they just die and with a thousand plus of
these things you are pretty much guaranteed to
have regular failures and the maintenance that
goes along with them at that point why wouldn't
you just buy proper ssds or hard drives in
the first place right but we have all these
massive corporations creating dozens of massive
multi-billion dollar data centers to host all of
your content and this network of hard drives is
called the cloud here it is this is your future
but where's the fun in that I mean I bet they
save so much space with all these unfortunately
these companies are so secretive about their data
capacity they even hide the exact size and power
consumption of their data centers so we can't even
extrapolate how many hard drives they must have
John John I tried to hire someone to sneak into a
data center for me to find out but no apparently
that's illegal or whatever that means so no I
don't know exactly how many hard drives make
up the cloud of one of these companies however I
do think they're each in the ballpark of around
30 exabytes if they're not there now they will be
very soon trust me that's 30 000 petabytes or 30
million terabytes if they use micro SD cards they
could condense their entire cloud and to adjust
this see they're wasting so much space when they
could just have this and call it a day come on
guys if you need any help I've got extras okay it
wouldn't be a scale video if I didn't show you the
max What's the total amount of data storage in the
entire world again it's kind of a tricky number to
find there's a difference between the amount of
data being generated replicated and deleted and
the actual installed data capacity crazily enough
ninety percent of all data never ends up getting
saved but if you were to count up all of the
hard drives memory cards phones smart hot tubs
and everything else in 2022 we would end up with
10 zettabytes see I told you we'd come back to
zettabytes 10 zettabytes is 10 billion terabytes
and a billion is already such a huge number I made
a whole video about it so 10 billion memory
cards well it cost over one trillion dollars
and here it is 10 billion memory cards yeah that's
right they fit in a single tennis court that is
a lot of memory cards but I don't know I guess I
was just kind of expecting it to be a lot larger
after all this does hold the entire world's
data it's really a testament to how insanely
data dense memory cards have become it's almost
disappointing because I wanted something truly
gargantuan to show you but it's probably
a bad idea to get a little crazy isn't it
hell no it's not a bad idea that's right we're
going there I had to know the bits 80 billion
trillion of these could store everything
and it should be arriving right about now
this Celestial bit is so large that
its own gravity takes over collapsing
itself into a Mini Moon two and a half
thousand kilometers wide this thing is
four million times larger than the
asteroid that ended the dinosaurs
a Planet Killer or a tennis court both contain the
same amount of information just in very different
ways it seems like we can't possibly get more
data dense than this but let's not forget the
ultimate data storage technology DNA because
a double helix strand of human DNA contains
215 petabytes of information but that's just
one we have 1.7 quadrillion strands of DNA
in our bodies you thought ten zettabytes
was big try 370 billion zettabytes that's
the data capacity we each carry with us every
day because we are the ultimate thumb drives
I think technology still has a long
way to go before beating biology
I hope thank you so much for watching
it feels great to be making these
making these series for your
viewing convenience right here
I guess I'll see you next time when I
visualize the scale of nuclear explosion
but for now I'm going to get back to our
quarter digital live stream every month
I'm back it holds 1.4 megabytes
of space so how many of oh